tras varias semanas de tempestad en las
que su plan de presupuesto provocó la
caída de la libra cristos necesitaba un
estímulo su discurso la conferencia del
partido conservador alentó a la
audiencia
tengo tres prioridades para nuestra
economía crecimiento crecimiento
crecimiento
el crecimiento fue prácticamente un
mantra en un discurso más breve de lo
habitual ofrecido por un líder Trust
admitió que los ahora archivados
recortes de impuestos para personas con
altos ingresos se habían convertido en
una distracción pero prometió una nueva
era de prosperidad para Reino Unido
libre de la supervisión de la Unión
Europea
estamos construyendo una economía que
aprovecha el máximo las enormes
oportunidades que ofrece el brexit a
finales de año todos los trámites
burocráticos con la Unión Europea
pasarán a la historia pero las cláusulas
propuestas podrían no ser tan populares
fuera del partido conservador como lo
demuestra una breve protesta de los
activistas de greenpeace quienes
acusaron a Trust de traicionar el
manifiesto electoral de su propio
partido Trust de los intentos de su
gobierno para hacer frente a la crisis
energética y dijo que la seguridad
energética era esencial para enfrentar
los nuevos desafíos geopolíticos
nos volvimos demasiado dependientes de
los regímenes autoritarios para obtener
bienes baratos y energía barata y no le
hicimos frente a Rusia lo
suficientemente pronto nos aseguraremos
de que esto nunca vuelva a suceder
La charla sobre el éxito futuro y los
impuestos bajos fue recibida
alentadoramente Por quienes asedian a la
primera ministra pero como los Stories
van detrás de los laboristas en las
encuestas por un amplio margen es
posible que el Distroller necesite algo
más que buenas palabras para ganarse a
su partido a largo plazo